i'm gonna show you how to take this old
dresser drawer
and turn it into a garden
with my full capabilities there is no
end to the bounty
of mother nature there's enough for
everybody
and that's one thing that you will learn
from gardening
most importantly what i'm going to teach
you is how to grow your own food
in this class what you're going to learn
is how to take some of my favorite
vegetables and herbs
from planting to harvesting mint lettuce
sage sweet potatoes rosemary kale i know
a lot of people out there you don't like
leafy greens i don't either
put them in your diet anyway because
this is one of the healthiest things
that you can possibly eat
you're going to learn how to make the
most of any patch of soil
from sidewalks to rooftops to flower
pots and i know you're asking what the
hell is compost compost is
one of the sexiest things on the planet
this takes things out of the waste cycle
they don't wind up in the landfill
[Music]
these things are really important not
only to your garden
but to the planet
i call myself the gangster gardener
because to me having knowledge is
gangster
soil is gangster air is gangster
gardens to me represent freedom that's
one of the reasons
that i started growing food myself and i
had no idea
what happened in my community and then
around the world would happen just for
me
planning a strip in south central los
angeles
we are supposed to inspire each other to
wake up in and realize what's truly
important i wanted to bring your
creativity
into your space i want you to know that
you have
the power to do this
i'm ron finley and this is my master
class
you